you know what I said when my parents
asked me if I wanted to be a model as a
kid I said I don't want fat ugly girls
to hurt themselves thinking they got to
look like me
that's nice of you I guess
it's nice to be inside from the cold and
rain
it is
although I really do like the rain you
like the rain I love it of course with
all the [__] to stay inside it's
cold in the tent no
not when you have a living blanket of
cats
oh that's right you're a cat lady how
many cats do you have at the moment
the ones I can touch with my hands I
have five
there's about three wandering in the
wastelands out here but the cats keep
you warm in Winter yeah
they really do I wake up with cats all
over me it's like the most wonderful
problem to have
I don't even lint roll anymore I'm proud
of my cat fur
I earned the nickname crazy cat lady
you've been in the streets know how long
I think it's like a year
my relationship with time is still fuzzy
but thanks to Casio
I'm reconnecting I might even
reintegrate
what do you see for the next year it'll
be a new year in a couple days I mean
I'm
trying to fundraise to get out to New
York because that's where my son is and
his dad and I would love to be a part of
my family again
I don't have very much out here
not that I don't
you know what I mean
family
all your friends and connections are
there
um no I don't I've never been there I
don't know anybody there except for my
son I don't actually I can't say I know
my son yet but I know his dad
but um that's my home with those two men
um can't imagine I always used to say if
there's anywhere in the world that
anybody actually wanted me to be I would
be there in a heartbeat and I found it
and I'm going
to knock on wood good for you
yeah that's exciting it's terrifying is
it terrifying yeah I think you touched
on something there
and and terrifying is probably the best
word because I'm living a straight life
and doing what the rest of us do
you know get a job
pay bills pay taxes live a straight life
not only that but
being a mom that's crazy that's
I can't like I I really really give it
up to all these ladies out here who are
raising kids in tents and [__]
uh
there's not a lot of that
there's I met someone who was third
generation Skid Row like his his
grandmother was born out here or some
something most people who are living in
tents have lost their kids
well of course because because they're
living in a tent
but uh and they're on drugs you know
yeah right I actually kind of excited to
get sober
like drugs are are you gonna try to wean
off of crystal meth
yeah it's
I'm sure I would do much better with a
prescription for Adderall and like a
good reason to live so
um have you tried to get clean before I
dropped meth cold turkey
twice
um it's been like seven years or so on
my current Bender but how was it when
you tried to get clean
it wasn't that hard to smoke a lot of
weed
stay busy
staying busy is like my my thing so and
how old is your son when he's three
years old he just turned three yeah
three-year-old will keep you busy
um yeah
yeah
woof but I'm really excited about it you
should be I would love to be a part of
his life
you know and all the interviews I've
done I've had very few mothers
say they're gonna pack up everything and
go spend time with my kids you know this
is crazy quit the drugs it's part of the
crazy cat lady thing but
because of my relationship with my cats
I can't feel good about myself in any
way shape or form if I'm not a part of
my son's life because
their mother teaches them how to be a
cat
and I mean if he's any part of me which
he's at least half me
he's gonna need me in his life to
understand like why things are so
parents are important I especially mommy
though well for me my mom was my best
friend she was everything I still still
haven't dealt with how I feel about
losing her so I can't imagine him not
really understanding truly what the word
mommy means in in a real sense like
that's shitty that's shitty behavior and
I hold myself to a higher standard
hahaha
and uh I owe it to my mom she she was
alive right now she would literally beat
my ass for not being there for him
she wouldn't care about any of the drug
use what is it that's kept you away for
the three years
myself I guess grieving my mother
partially drug use of course but
I still haven't quite figured out
exactly how to get out of my own way
is some of it just self-sabotage
yeah or just being scared to like fill
in my mom's shoes in a way but we were
literally the exact same shoe size so
that's not that shouldn't be a problem
I just don't want to let him down
because so far I think I made the right
decision by giving him up and letting
him go to New York where his dad is a
big family but
I can't just
keep going with my life knowing that
part of me is out there somewhere and I
didn't do anything to
contribute to that because I would have
been lost without my mom
I gotta try
the trait that I've seen in people who
have
been able to get away from this
lifestyle
is to have the self-worth
to say
this is not acceptable for me
living in a tent
and rummaging around for drugs
is not something I want in my life
anymore
I think the reason that so many people
are down here living in tents rummaging
around for drugs is because their
self-worth is so low
they're broken their self-worth is
broken
I fortunately am completely
self-centered maybe even a little
narcissistic
no I'm kidding I just my mother spoiled
the [__] out of me and she taught me how
to spoil myself
I but that doesn't necessarily build
self-worth esteem it's like standards of
living like I am not even comfortable
living in a tent yeah I know although I
have a beautiful tenderness
came from good families yeah I know they
still have Rich families out there like
trying to get them to come home and be a
part of their lives but they would
rather be out here garbage digging and
yeah but if they're self-worth their
self-esteem was intact they would wake
up one morning and say
what the [__] am I doing down here
why am I living in a tent on the street
and do something to get their ass out of
here why am I living in Italian so far
I I've noticed a lot of people out here
just need like some mental help yeah
mental health self-worth yeah it's kind
of the same thing and um honestly not
having my cell phone anymore I miss my
old therapist like
I want to go back into the area of
working on my mental health and being a
person like a contributing member of
society indoors person who takes herself
shopping in [__]
who buys Christmas presents for her
family and like
pays taxes
it sounds exciting those are esteem
building Acts
sorry what those are esteem building
yeah and it's I've never actually done
my own taxes it's another thing that's
terrifying but you know what challenge
accepted I can't [__] wait
I can't wait
mostly to take myself shopping again I
need to make sure that my shopping
addiction is passed on to my son
could be worse addictions absolutely
like cats cat hoarding
no yes
okay that's very exciting
I just hope he's as excited about it as
I am it's nice to your ex-boyfriend or
the father of your child
um he's not even my ex-boyfriend or the
father of your child
yeah but he wants you back
I mean I don't I don't know if we're
going that far with it I really don't
know I don't know what to expect from it
he just is concerned that I'm living
this lifestyle and he
I took him in once upon a time when I
owned a house and blah blah
and um I don't think that he like thinks
he owes me the same but he gives a [__]
he gives a [__] about me because I'm the
other half of his pride and joy and um
God bless him for that
I am so grateful and I mean obviously I
would I'm not going to say how I feel
about that part of it whether it gets
romantic or not I don't give a [__]
because he's the best dad that that my
son could ever have asked for
and um
I don't know I just
I hope I can like match those standards
I can totally imagine you as a great mom
thank you
my cats think so too
the cats are coming with you
he said I could bring a few I mean
we'll see I'm bringing at least one okay
it's not so bad
yeah
it's crazy having like a reason to live
again though
rediscovering fear and [__] that's
that's kind of fun too honestly
when you have to do something that
scares the crap out of you adrenaline
yeah can help you do it it really does
when that moment comes
well that's what you don't factor in
sometimes I thought that spiders were
the only thing that scared the crap out
of me but
I think like living actually living
being a participating member of my life
is
something that I didn't know was scary
but
I like facing my fears anyway so it's
like the whole thing behind theme parks
right
roller coasters
courage is What's missing
so much of so many of us seem to lack
the courage to do what's to do what's
required in a lot of situations I think
it's
sad that people say when you try to
commit suicide you're cowardly because
that takes a lot of Courage [__] I
couldn't do it but I mean if you have
enough courage to try that why not just
flip it around and try to live
try to do the thing have a little bit of
fun
I mean
I think suicide
usually happens when there's something
wrong mentally
well it's not just that you're sad and
your lifestyle yeah it's usually
multiple usually there's something else
going on yeah
and um
I made peace with that whole part of my
soul
um
now I just got to make peace with the
part of me that still wants to live I
guess
no I can't wait I can't wait for my life
to get peaceful and happy and boring
I've had enough interesting
living no where is this life going to
take you you're going to be 70 years old
living on the streets everywhere
there's a couple of those out here I
know
shuffling around with their shopping
carts
Honestly though well I don't know
I thought I never wanted to be that old
but like I kind of can't wait to be a
grandparent
like gray-haired and old and telling
kids to get off my lawn and stuff I
can't wait to have a lawn again too
I think I'm ready I'm ready to start
living again
and turn all this
whatever this is this Darkness into like
a better color it's beautiful
yeah I'd like to check in with you again
in a couple years
and see where you're at then
well hopefully it's somewhere better
than this
no it doesn't get much worse
I don't know every time I say that life
proves me wrong
so um only up from here onward and
upward forward
That's so exciting
married cat I wish you all the luck in
the world thank you
thank you very much